google street view sie kennen das da
kann man im internet durch die straßen
der welt laufen weil google vorher mal
alles abgefilmt hat mit solchen kamera
autos ja auf diesen bildern von google
street view hat die polizei jetzt eine
spektakuläre entdeckung gemacht auf
diesem foto nämlich da hat google einen
mann gefunden der seit 20 jahren
verschwunden war schauen sie mal hin mir
war der bisher unbekannt aber der
polizei war dieser mann bekannt und zwar
sehr bekannt er wurde seit 20 jahren
gesucht und was ist mit diesem mann
genau auf sich hat das zeigen jetzt
hier wird nach zwanzigjähriger fahndung
ein italienischer mafiaboss festgenommen
mit der hilfe von kommissar zufall denn
der mafiosi fällt der genauigkeit des
google dienstes street view zum opfer
der kartendienst des internetriesen hat
einen kleinen obst und gemüseladen im
spanischen ort galapagos in der nähe von
madrid fotografiert und vor diesen
stehen zwei männer einen davon haben die
ermittler als kino camino identifiziert
der mittlerweile 60-jährige ist 2002 aus
einem gefängnis in rom ausgebrochen
nachdem er dort wegen mordes ein
gesessen hat er taucht damals abgibt
sich in spanien eine neue identität und
eröffnet sogar ein geschäft diesen
kleinen laden eben namens alberto der
manu mit hilfe von kommissar zufall oder
genauer kommissar street view wird der
mafiosi jetzt aber den rest seiner
lebenslänglichen strafe im gefängnis in
rom absitzen
unglaubliche geschichte die spanischen
behörden konnten den mafiaboss dann am
17 dezember festnehmen er wird jetzt
eine lebenslange haftstrafe fortsetzen
aus der vor 20 jahren geteilt war und
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit unserem
bild reporter kai feldhaus wie kam die
polizei überhaupt darauf bei google
street view nach zu wühlen die polizei
hat offenbar seit mehreren jahren den
verdacht dass sich kilogramm ihn nach
spanien abgesetzt
es gab da wohl auch schon hinweise und
sie waren dann wohl auf der suche nach
einem obstladen der da eine rolle
spielte und wie man das dann macht man
guckt wo ist die adresse geht es für
google maps ein sieht das dann okay in
spanien funktioniert googles video da
gucken wir da mal rein sind die straße
entlang gefahren hat man gesagt ach guck
mal das könnte doch sein soll steht ja
ja und es ist also recht ja okay das
klingt nach also ein bisschen zeit hat
es gebraucht aber dann relativ schneller
fahndungserfolg sozusagen beschreibt uns
ein bisschen mehr welcher mann der
polizei dann die fänge gegangen
camino war in den 80er jahren eine ganz
große nummer in der spd dies die das ist
eine splittergruppe der sizilianischen
cosa nostra aus agent aus sizilien die
sich von der mutterorganisation
abgespalten hat sich mit denen dann
blutige revierkämpfe geliefert hat
die erste aktenkundige verurteilung von
garmin und starb vor 1984 da hat ihn der
legendäre mafiajäger giovanni falcone
verknackt der ja dann unter 92 die luft
gejagt wurde
1989 dann das verbrechen wegen dem
garmin 0 1 saß da hat er einen passanten
erschossen der fälschlicherweise für
einen rivalen hielt er kam dann in haft
und aus dieser haft ist er 2002 auf
spektakuläre art und weise entflohen da
wurde nämlich in dem knast in dem er saß
in rom ein film gedreht und als sie
fertig waren ist senior camino gemeinsam
mit den komparsen aus dem knast raus
spaziert und hat sich da womöglich sogar
schon nach spanien abgesetzt ansehen
sondern auch spektakuläre art und weise
aus dem knast raus jetzt auf
spektakuläre art und weise wieder in den
knast rein jetzt haben wir ihn gerade an
diesem obstladen gesehen dort bei google
street view er und seine familie haben
aber mit obst nicht das geldverdienen
sondern womit
in
in italien ganz klar mit den klassischen
mafia fachbereichen mit drogenhandel
prostitution korruption
als er dann nach spanien sich abgesetzt
hat ist er zumindest was das verbrechen
angeht nicht mehr groß aufgefallen er
hat dann ein restaurant betrieben das
ließ la cucina dem manuel hatte sich der
manuell in spanien das wurde 2018
geschlossen und dann hat er hat diesen
kleinen obstler alberto de mayo der
gemüsegarten mahnung offensichtlich als
als
zur verdeckung und irgendwie seinen
lebensunterhalt ein bisschen zu
bewerkstelligen unglaubliche geschichte
ich bin gespannt zu ende wenn jemand das
zu einem drehbuch macht sind diese
geschichte verfilmt ja er gehört zur
sizilianischen mafia stella und darüber
wollen wir mehr erfahren und darüber
sprechen wir jetzt mit dem kriminalisten
christian matzdorf uns zugeschaltet
schön dass sie bei uns sind welche rolle
spielt dieser stiller klar denn
überhaupt der mafia geflecht
guten morgen im verhältnis zu den großen
playern in der italienischen mafia
camorra
cosa nostra ist dies wieder eine
tatsächlich kleine wie er fällt auch
schon sagte splittergruppe ab später und
der cosa nostra des sizilianischen mafia
die hauptsächlich mit geldwäsche
drogenhandel
ihr geld verdient gehst du da ist ein
kleiner ableger insofern als man in
deutschland von ungefähr 30 mitgliedern
spricht also mit dem zufolge ein fall
dass wir anderen etwas unauffälliger
klein aber unauffällig bedeutet nicht
dass diese mafia absplitterungen nicht
gefährlich ist viele denken die mafia
das ist so eine sache der 80er 90er
jahre spätestens noch aber ist nicht so
die ist richtig aktiv
ja die mafia ist aktiv es geht bei der
mafia wenn sie insgesamt betrachten
nicht um millionengewinne aus illegalen
geschäften es geht um milliardensummen
diese summen die wir natürlich nicht nur
in italien verdient aber sie müssen eben
auch angelegt wenn sie wieder in anderen
ländern verdient und man versucht das
geld natürlich dort zu investieren wo es
unauffällig ist geld welches etwas was
man nicht sieht und hört nicht
wahrnehmen kann das muss möglichst
dezent passieren und dafür ist
deutschland ein sehr geeigneter
rückzugsraum gehen auch die sticker
nutzt
also das bedeutet deutschland ist er so
einen nebenschauplatz lösungen kleine
vielleicht versteck möglichkeit aber
nicht wirklich spielt die mache hier
noch eine rolle
das würde ich nicht ganz so sagen die
aktivitäten der mafia die sind in
deutschland weniger stark sichtbar das
hat natürlich damit zu tun dass die ihre
geschäfte nicht gefährden wollen also
schießerei noch auf einer straße werden
so erheblich ermittlungshandlungen
führen und würden das was ich machen
wollte nämlich illegal geld verdienen
stören also verhält man sich dezent
geldwäsche immobiliengeschäfts
investitionen oder rauschgift hatte
entwickelt man ruhig und möglichst
unauffällig ab in beim württemberg
niedersachsen wo die ist ja
hauptsächlich in deutschland vertreten
ist und daran gibt es natürlich gerade
die geldwäsche thematik die wir
angesprochen haben hier und da sind die
schon aktiv sie müssen eben auch geld
aus italien in deutschland investieren
und zwar in einer art und weise die
nicht auffällt und deshalb sagen wir mal
helfe wenig auffällig im dunkelfeld in
aktivitäten sicherlich maximal aktiver
jetzt haben wir gerade gesehen dass
dieser herr herter vor dem spanischen
obstladen geschnappt wurde mit hilfe von
google street view dass der 20 jahre
lang vermisst wurde verschwunden war
gesucht wurde wie viel von diesen großen
köpfen laufen denn frei rum im moment
die international gesucht werden seit
vielen vielen jahren kann man das
ungefähr beziffern
also dazu eine zahl zu nennen das wäre
unseriös denn die verfahren laut die
sind ja sehr dynamisch das heißt es gibt
veränderungen auch in der maschine
bedeutung dieser person gerade im hunde
der mafia struktur wir können das nicht
genau beziffern wir müssen aber davon
ausgehen dass wir auch aus den mittleren
führungsfehler der mafia also nicht die
ganz ganz große gruppe sondern eben aus
der mittleren führungsebene sollte man
das management bezeichnet eine vielzahl
von personen haben die untergetaucht
sind mit shine identitäten auch nicht
nur in italien sondern eben im ausland
leben hier dieser mann in spanien und
auch aktivierbar sind für die
organisation eben wieder bestimmte
geschäfte durchzuführen wenn es dann
gerade passt also wenn beispielsweise
wie in diesem fall
spanien interessant werden würde könnte
man diese menschen schläfer ähnlich
würde ich sagen dann doch wieder
aktivieren und in kriminelle geschäfte
einbinden
der kriminalist vielen herzlichen dank
für diese informationen und auf ihren
natürlichen dank eines unser kollege der
diesen spektakulären fall und sei klar
dass mit gebracht hat ich bin sicher es
wird ein film draus